this is me on the subway and there's a
person here you know this is my
corresponding yours the stander and
there's your
sitter looker at dicker
they're just right there i mean that's
what they have no choice they're
sitting like this and you're standing
over there
i mean women are decent and they stand
like sideways but we just go like
there you go didn't she for the first
five years have like midgets who wanted
to bang their mailman's boyfriend and
she and she didn't want to do it
but she stood on the heads of those
little people
for five years until she got and then
she's sitting there across from this guy
like
so how could you you know exactly what
he's doing
it's the stupidest thing i've ever seen
title undetermined at this point
chairman of the board
oh all right do something with that you
i i got the board to spell b-o-r-e-d
[Applause]
i mean you know your voice is important
but you don't know how important it is
until you lose it
because you can't really communicate and
everything comes off rude like
you just look rude like when you're
talking to people
i'm watching a ball game and all of a
sudden everybody stands up
holding up a sign of somebody that they
either know that's dying of cancer or
died of it in the middle of the game
it's just like what are you doing
trying to watch your game here no
there's a time and a place
look i know somebody
i know somebody that has died of cancer
i would never go to the movies with you
and in the middle of it hit pause and be
like oh by the way conan
i know this guy he died
it was horrific i could have lifted him
up off the sheet with two fingers it was
horrible hey enjoy by the way i got
molested when i was nine
enjoy the list i tell you this
what's that norm my doctor told me i'm
on the same dose
that they give to the donkey for the
second show in tijuana okay now
for the second show you know why do i
continue to have you on
worried about this environmental stuff
you really are worried about it i
am and i'm not i just also feel like you
know it'd probably be a good thing if
most of us died
you know what i mean it would be have
you ever thought like
idiot at the end of a sentence but you
don't say it like it's right over there
i didn't have to do that it's right over
there
like i'll go on my computer and i'll
like google an image that i don't want
to see so then i see a whole
wall of it yeah you know like big dicks
with nails in them
[Laughter]
sir you're going to have to leave the
library yeah
i was on tour i brought this leather
jacket and it had a peace sign
on the back of it it was like a
rhinestone peace sign i said you know
what i'm doing the end of my show
i'm gonna turn around show the back of
my jacket and put up a peace sign
the crowd's gonna go off i did it nobody
said nothing
one person was like what's that on his
back
[Laughter]
we had all these waffles eggs bacon this
whole layout my brother was looking at
half-eaten cube
steaks so he looked at my mom and goes
mom can i have a waffle
she goes no that is your breakfast and
he goes oh mom i hate you
and my dad without looking up took a
full glass of milk and threw it in his
face
can i help you in any way yeah no just
anything anything makes it look just a
little bit
yeah like or medical right look at this
right
this is right so
like there's explosions and acrobats but
they're looking at it
through a little three-inch screen like
i think if jesus comes back
and starts telling everyone everything
it'll just everybody's just gonna be
twittering and they won't be like i am
christ and i have retained
oh my god jesus is right in front of me
[Applause]
oh that's he's got the double flap going
on oh my god
look at this oh that is
[Applause]
you changed our show all right it's like
nine and a half weeks but carrot top
wow i gotta check out that movie
is it called nine and a half seconds
it's like his premature ejaculatory
you know i hit her with another one and
she booed me like for real
your daughter she gave me three kid like
booze like boo
boo and even though she's a kid i got
mad like yeah yeah
i i swear to you i know exactly what
you're talking about
i got mad like she was sitting in her
little chair and like the legs aren't
sturdy so i kicked one of the legs and
she fell
you know how i would do it what i would
i would randomly sink cruise ships
yeah what why would you randomly think
cruise ships
because you'd get like 2500 to 3 000
people of whack
right and i don't think i think it's a
good mix of people to get rid of
i have noticed that like women can be
friends with each other but you can't
force them to hang out with each other
like you couldn't do a heist with women
does that make sense
like ocean's 11 with women wouldn't work
because two would keep breaking off to
talk trash about the other night
it's uh stunning how uh jay leno
outfoxed you again
yeah he's good
like everybody's like oh jay leno they
do the voice
meanwhile he's the shrewdest guy he
outfoxed
you're in good company he had fox johnny
carson
david letterman every 10 years some
red-headed rube shows up
so that's the phone call you got yeah
yeah oh your agent's like is good news
and bad news
you are doing the tonight show it's true
but
remember that discussion where we had
where you said i'll never have to
[Laughter]
[Music]
follow
you saw that movie playing in the apes
of mark wahlberg the remake yeah
well yeah they're both racist to me man
like
the first one was like was like you know
just get your damn dirty ape hands off
i'm like oh come on what are you really
talking about
all right all right
and then i see the new one i'm thinking
this is a more progressive time this
will not be as racist
and then they had the apes was sitting
at dinner yeah i'm not even making stuff
they was eating watermelon i was like oh
come on
eating watermelon and then like later on
in the movie they're running from the
apes and like running the water because
the apes can't swim
which is like oh word obviously these
apes can talk and
but they can't swim and then uh
at the end it's like when i seen the
apes smoking the newport i just got up
yeah you're right
[Music]
[Music]
you